have been Hollywood royalty for decades
uh a lot of the royal family hasn't
stopped them voicing their opinions on
them Kelly touch a podcast recently to
tell us exactly what she thought of
Prince Harry
I think Harry's
I do I think he's that I think he's a
he's a whining whinging complaining
woe is me I'm the only one that's ever
had mental problems
like my life was so hard everybody's
life is hard you were the prince
of a goddamn country who dressed up as a
Nazi and now you're trying to
come back as the Pope
suck it
no
I I mean I couldn't have put in quite
like that but I definitely share the
sentiment
um Sharon when you heard Kelly there and
you have a way with words Sharon you've
been slightly more polite about them
whilst making the same point
it was all very distasteful peers I was
totally bored by The Whining The Whining
the whining and you know the curtsy the
thing she said about Medieval Times her
lunch with the queen was like Medieval
Times which as you know is a Disney type
um entertainment place for kids and it's
just so horribly disrespectful and just
a wine vest
so here we are
um it's quite interesting what's
happened to them isn't it because I lost
my job because of Meghan Markle over
that Oprah interview you Sharon then
disgracefully lost Jules on the talk
because you basically said I was
entitled to my opinion
um where are they now these two because
it seems to me that people have
basically just got bored of them which
is the most lethal thing of all for any
public figures
who's gonna go first I just think the
proof is in the pudding in the sense
you've been handed the world and every
major contract you had podcasts you have
all of this and you didn't deliver
because you
because you don't have it and that's
that's okay and I think they do have a
right to privacy but that doesn't seem
to me what they're looking for an Aussie
Aussie let me ask Aussie actually
um about Sharon getting fired from the
talk because I felt so angry about that
that Sharon would be forced out of a job
that she was brilliant because she was
the star of that show what did you make
of it
but I always said it was accessible yeah
yeah
so we're looking for an excuse to get
her up
and it was uh it was a it was the time
when like what what better excuse to
kick someone off a show than you know
stop making wild allegations of like
racism and it was just it was the it was
like the The Fad of the moment to just
you know burn someone down just to you
know wave the woke flag and it was
ridiculous yeah it was completely
outrageous actually
um I mean obviously to hear people call
Sharon a racist knowing her as well as
you do how did you feel about that when
but when I first heard that you got
uh she's leaving the show
I I said well Cheryl was to go for it
she knows she's not all right girlfriend
and it was Sharon Cheryl that
threw her under the bus you did
yeah
that's the thing that was
no and that was the thing that was so
disappointing it's like you know all
these people that had worked with my mum
for double digit years knew the whole
family knew everything not anyone came
out and said hey actually that's that's
a pile of BS and and
they everyone just went with it because
for one people couldn't defend my mum
because if you do defend everyone then
jumps on you and it it was it was just
nuts and you know Sharon the interesting
thing isn't it if you go back to the
start of it I had to lose my job on Good
Morning Britain here in the UK because I
said I didn't believe a word Meghan
Markle said I wouldn't believe her if
she weren't a weather report well that's
been completely Vindicated by all the
lies which have been exposed since
including stuff that was lied about in
the Oprah interview so actually if you
take that as the starting point
everything that follow was completely
nuts
it just insanity and then it seemed you
know that that everybody was parted do
you like them do you not like them oh
I'm for them I'm against them and it's
like you know they were given far too
much importance because what do they do
yeah yeah well that's all they do
actually wonderful things with the games
he has done an amazing jobs yeah the
Invictus games is a very good thing it's
like this to his country was good but
the truth is the only value they have to
these corporations was to trash their
families
you guys are such an extraordinarily
strong family unit through thick and
thin always have been it's one of the
things I love about you most when you
see people who who basically disown
their entire families on both sides and
then pretend they're happy I don't see
how people can be happy when they do
that
no no no
children don't have any family yeah no
grandparents no no aunts no uncles no
cousins there's nothing nothing their
babies have their mom and dad and that
is what is so terribly sad yeah and they
don't they know nothing of their
Heritage where does this end Sharon
hello
I said it in the beginning in tears it's
it's going to end very very badly and I
don't know why it just keeps taking me
back to Edward and and Mrs Simpson it's
like history repeating itself yeah
you know and I want to face you know
cuddly lovey holding hands going
everywhere together it's so disingenuous
it's like come on
give us a break from all of that Aussie
having been through
well I've talked to you Aussie about
love because you have one of the
greatest marriages for Watson all good
bad and ugly now you've had it all over
the decades but you're one of the
greatest marriages I know because it's
actually based at his heart on true love
and for you what is it about that woman
on the end of that sofa right now that's
kept you sitting there and so in love
with her for so long
I
and she'll strangle them if he leaves
you always want to leave or come back to
all my clothes are destroyed stop
and Sharon for you what is the what is
the secret of longevity in a marriage do
you think
you have to realize that you can't
change anybody in its acceptance and of
course the bottom line is love but you
accept each other you know as you are
you can't change anybody yeah
we're going to take a short break we
have to change themselves yeah I think
that's right and you evolve you evolve
as people right but I do think when I
look at the four of you sitting there I
remember I think about all the scrapes
you've been through collectively
individually whatever it's it's great to
see you guys sitting there as this
fantastic founder unit
you know all of you having come through
difficult times